barricade soldiers and checkpoints they
don't just separate the Palestinian
territories from Israel here in the West
Bank they also split the city of Hebron
is it okay apparently it's not
I'm with Saunders a Palestinian student
who lives on the other side of this
checkpoint right by a Jewish settlement
we know their rules more than you we
know okay there we go straight then left
yeah yeah to my house before we do
something we tell the camel in the bus
is everything okay
but you see we have guns we have guns we
have guns here till you have a gun and
you know no big whatever just tell me
what the problem
like why wouldn't you want me to know
their security reason the soldiers are
here to protect Israeli settlers from
attacks and from us to I guess is okay
no excuse me it's not my job to call
them attack or to call anyone from
Israeli government okay you have to do
something he's the commander he can do
something okay you want me to pass the
phone to the commander who told me to
call you
there is assessment and they for me I
have the permission to go there and
anyone that's you know I have a lot of
faith astir they came from there they
passed from this gate and it was not
problems there is no problem for special
journalists as international it's not
it's allowed to them to to be anywhere
they want so Karen all so why do you
think they're doing it
this is I don't know some soldiers
really it depends to their moods some
soldiers they said okay it's it's our
job we have to do it I still don't know
so what did he say who was that man he's
from them attack okay
dem attack is responsible for the
communication between us and the
Palestinians basically there was a
misunderstanding
no comment so we get to go now yes you
can go I'm sorry from the convenience
and everything but you know the
procedure is is complicated
in this Jewish Israeli settlement in
Hebron avoidance is the name of the game
no one has a problem with me using the
roads but some does who lives here isn't
allowed to because she's Palestinian
this is the path she takes to get home
today two Israeli acquaintances are
visiting from Tel Aviv
besides the settlers not many Jewish
Israelis come here for the guests it's a
two-hour drive into an unfamiliar world
yeah yes underseas neighbor is a
well-known right-wing nationalist
politician conflict here seems pretty
much unavoidable first time he threw
stones and we were here I second time I
was here and I took stone here the third
time we were there but they and he was
here so he threw stones there but no one
like exactly injured do you appreciate
Israeli people coming over here yeah
it's really nice because it's completely
different between Israel and Israeli
settlers be careful because yours is
it's not like these people you know do
you think that by building up the wall
the separation wall between between the
two sides the Green Line yeah does that
make it worse the world is there because
before that there was you know suicide
bomber every every other month I just
think that this is good for putting out
a fire but it's not it's far from being
a long-term solution it's only you know
aggregating bitterness and an anger and
you know no no wonder we are you know
experiencing what we are experiencing
sunders gives tours to visitors from
other countries telling them her side of
the story a story of the ongoing
struggle between Palestinians and
settlers where tensions regulate end in
violence perpetrated by both sides woman
she catched my brother
it took a big stone and she tried to to
put the stone inside his mouth but
luckily he closed his cheese and she
only crushed in his teeth which is like
gay soldiers Israeli soldiers came and
so what happened and they saw exactly
what the settler woman makes my brother
luckily the when it occurred happened
the soldier told it of the court the
truth do you think there's anything that
we can do as people I was in Yerevan I
sometimes I I heard from a lot of people
like they asked me where I'm from so I
said Palestine so they said what
where's Palestine so this is really big
problem for me and it's really hard the
22 year old act as a kind of ambassador
whether or not she even has a country
son decide enta Phi's very much with her
culture although sometimes she'd prefer
not to wear her headscarf
but the people in the Arab part of
Hebron are quite conservative
nonetheless she'd rather live there than
in the Jewish settlement but that's not
an option for her family the house where
they live belongs to relatives and they
don't want to leave it to settlers she
wants to show me around her bronze
ancient city centre to get there we have
to go through another checkpoint one of
around 20 here Sanders passes through
them several times a day on her way to
university to the shops whenever she
wants to go anywhere 200,000 people live
in Hebron making it the biggest city in
the West Bank it's also the only one
with Jewish settlements at the center of
town this place the tomb of Abraham
makes it a holy city for both Jews and
Muslims thousands of Israeli soldiers
are stationed here to protect around 600
Jewish settlers unrest here is
commonplace
the city is witness to attacks riots and
murders on both sides some incredibly
heinous acts the defense also to protect
themselves from settlers stones of
course it doesn't it doesn't take them
from dirty water and also they throw
like a chemical water yeah
this was once the busiest street in the
city that's before it was blocked off
for the settlers and more than 1800
Palestinian shops were shut down sunders
isn't allowed to come here but I am and
I want to talk to the settlers no I know
no English
finally the student from a religious
school agrees to talk to me we have to
take guns with us we have taken the yes
lives because it's dangerous look I
believe that the these countries it's
our country 4000 years I believe that
God gave it gave it to a rom it's ours
have you also heard of settlers
attacking Palestinians we know Naruto
you know if some Palestinian stuck me so
why defends myself but we don't we don't
fight them at all you think they want us
here you think they want peace
complicated
sadly the longer I'm here and the more I
talk to people on both sides the less
hope I have that this conflict will ever
end
the wall between Israel and the West
Bank stretches more than 700 kilometers
and its construction is nowhere near
complete right behind this wall is
Jerusalem sunders has family there but
to visit them she needs special
permission and that is not easy to get
would not exist anymore that would
change anything
first we are under occupation and if
there's no wall Israeli government will
put more and more checkpoints so in my
opinion I don't think so that they will
change anything I'd like to be free in
my land to go anywhere I want without
any checkpoint without any permissions
but of course we'd we are all up to
mistake we were patient also so yeah I
hope so something will change in the
future
I don't know change is a big word in
Israel and the West Bank where religion
and politics have created huge walls
that cut through the land and were still
through people's hearts and minds